[ Music ]
[Christmas Seals fight Tuberculosis]
[The National Tuberculosis Association in
cooperation with the United States]
[Office of Indian Affairs presents]
[Another to Conquer]
[The cast, Slow-Talker... Howard Gorman, Don
his grandson... Sammy Day, Nema, his granddaughter...
Geraldine H. Birdsbill, Robert a friend...
Richard Hogner, Director... W. W. Peter, M.D.]
[Director... Edgar G. Ulmer, Camera... Robert
Cline, Sound... Clarence Townsend, Consultant...
Ruth Underhill, Ph. D., Editor... H. E. Mandl;
RCA, Springer Pictures Inc.]
[The generous assistance of the Navajo Service
is gratefully acknowledged.]
[Narrator:] Long before the white man came
to the new world, the American Indians occupied
the broad land we now called the United States.
They were a great people of many tribes. Some
lived in the desert, others on the plains,
still others in the forest, on the lakes and
rivers.
Their natural enemies were numerous. And in
addition, tribal wars and feuds took their
toll. Yet always, the Indians faced their
foes without fear.
Their sons and daughters of today face new
enemies. One of them is a cruel disease- tuberculosis,
which steals away the strength of the victim
until he is lifeless.
Yet Indians of today have not lost the courage
of their fathers and this courage will not
fail them. This enemy too, they will conquer.
[Sound of horse and wagon approaching.]
[Slow-Talker:] Never look back to the house
of the dead. It is our custom that we leave
our dead in peace. Grandson, your father has
gone back to earth. We start anew.
[Don:] Grandpa, will the cough kill my mother
too?
[Slow-Talker:] O'la. Who knows.
[Melancholy music]
[A dozen years swept on. Zonchee, the mother,
died, too. But grandfather Slow-Talker held
the little family together: the lovely Nema
and Don his ardent admirer.
Robert, their neighbor, was a frequent visitor. Together they worked and played and took part in the folk ways.]
[Chanting, singing, and drumming are heard and people are shown moving in a circle around a fire.]
An elder begins speaking.
[Don:] Slow-Talker is running. We have always
gone out to meet our enemies, but now no more.
Now we die.
[Robert:] Yes, we die. But it is sad. First
your mother, then your father died of tuberculosis.
[Don:] He says we die because we do not keep
the old customs.
[Robert:] I wonder. Slow-Talker's brave, yes.
But he may be mistaken; the old weapons of
our fathers cannot fight tuberculosis.
[Nema:] You mean, we should heed the white
doctors?
[Don:] I am loyal to the old man.
[ Chanting ]
[Robert:] Nema, I have news. I am going to
the boarding school.
[Nema:] Yeah, is your mind really made up?
[Robert:] Yes, I honor our people, respect
them, but white people have much to share
with us. I will learn something and live better.
[Nema:] And... you will come back.
[Chanting and drumming.]
[Music plays as Robert saddles up his horse.]
[Robert:] Goodbye Nema
[Nema:] Goodbye Robert.
[Robert:] Goodbye Slow-Talker.
[Slow-Talker:] Goodbye.
[Nema watches as the men and horses ride away ]
[Slow-Talker:] Forsaking the ways of his people.
[Horses galloping down a hill and across a desert landscape.]
[The two men are shown walking towards a white building.]
[Narrator:] The ways part for these two comrades.
Good luck to you says Don, as Robert faces
new experiences in school. It all seems strange
at first but Robert soon likes it.
And he learns fast.
He discovers the wisdom left by others in
books. Both mind and hand are trained. He
learns the skillful use of tools and machines.
Order and cleanliness become part of his daily
life.
Sports and games help him to build a strong
body and fit muscles and train him in the
art of team play with his fellows.
[ Music ]
[Whistle blows]
[The boys gather around the coach.]
[Coach:] Boys, a doctor has come to make the
physical examination.
[Doctor:] Boys, you all look strong, but there
are the invisible worms that can harm the
body. We call them germs, and so each student
gets a physical examination.
Robert, I think I'll start with you first.
[The doctor is shown examining and listening to Robert's chest.]
[Doctor:] Ever thump a covered water barrel to hear
how full it is? This is just like that. Doctors
learn how lungs sound when healthy and when
sick.
[Robert:] Warriors put their ears to the ground
to hear the footsteps of their enemy.
[Doctor:] Is that so? We have the same idea.
Lungs make sound, one kind of sound when healthy,
another kind when sick. Stand here please,
Robert.
Chin up there, shoulders against. That's it.
X-rays we call them. The rays pass right through
the body and throw a shadow picture on the
film in the holder.
Take a deep breath, hold it. Finished.
Now, tomorrow when this film is developed
I will show you a picture of your heart and lungs.
Here, Robert, is the X-ray picture of your
lungs taken yesterday. These are the collarbones.
The ribs, lung, all healthy, healthy, all
healthy but that spot, see it? That spot is
made by tuberculosis, Robert.
[Robert:] No. Tuberculosis? But I am so well.
I don't cough, it can't be.
[Doctor:] Don't be discouraged, Robert. The
lung will heal if you go at once to a sanatorium
and stay there until the doctor says you may
go home.
[Narrator:] And so Robert finds himself in
the sanatorium, where under the guidance of
doctors and nurses, he learns to fight his
enemy in bed.
[A man on a horse comes galloping through a canyon.]
[He pulls up and dismounts.]
[Nema:] How is Robert? Is he all right?
[Don:] He looks healthy.
[Slow-Talker:] He's just lazy, easygoing,
in bed, bah.
How long do you think he'll be in the hospital?
[Don:] I don't know. A long time, maybe. The
nurse says Robert must be quiet in bed [cough].
I told Robert he's a sissy.
[Slow-Talker:] Our ancestors were brave. They
stood on their feet and fought their enemies
until they were whipped. What's this I hear
today? Young men lazing around in bed. Bah.
[Nema:] But grandfather, perhaps that is not
the way to fight this enemy, on their feet.
When they do, they die.
[ Don coughing ]
[Nema:] Don, don't you think you should go
to the doctor?
[Don:] No, I am strong. Tomorrow I will be
better.
[Doctor:] Hello Robert. Mind if I sit down?
[Doctor:] Now that you're almost well I'd
like to tell you more about this disease.
You can help your people better than I can
to understand.
Here's the left lung. Here's the right. Here's
the windpipe.
The lung is soft like a sponge and it works
like a bellows. Tuberculosis usually starts
up here.
It may seem harmless at first, and heal in
a short time. But, sometimes it spreads.
Like a little patch of weeds, bit by bit it
destroys the lung.
Then the man begins to cough and spit up damaged
lung flesh. It spreads more.
The man loses his taste for food. He loses
weight, he gets weak and maybe spits up blood.
He goes weaker and thinner and at last he
dies.
[Robert:] Is there no medicine to stop this
disease?
[Doctor:] No. Though men have hunted for such
a medicine for years. But nature can stop
it, and heal it as it heals other sicknesses.
Robert, what do we do for a broken leg?
[Robert:] We tie it up with fixing straps.
[Doctor:] Exactly. Why? To keep it quiet so
it can heal. Doctors call that a splint.
We cannot tie up the lung, but we can rest
it by lying quietly in bed and gaining strength
from good food.
[Robert:] That makes sense. Now, will you
tell me again about that little operation
you did on me so I will be able to explain
it to my people.
[Doctor:] It is called pneumothorax. That
means air in the chest. Here, let me show you.
A small hollow needle is pushed through the
chest wall. Air flows in. The soft lung collapses
like squeezing wool.
It cannot breathe, it rests, it heals. When
it is all well again inside, the lung is allowed
to blow up and breathe again as before.
[Robert:] Wonderful. But here's what puzzles
me. What causes the disease? You told me once
before it was caused by a germ, but what is
a germ?
[Doctor:] Well, it's really a tiny living
thing. Some call it the invisible worm.
But it is alive. It grows. I can prove it
to you. Come, to the laboratory.
[Doctor:] Here in this tube is a kind of jelly,
clean, nothing on it.
Here is another, something growing on it.
A short time ago it was as clean as this one.
Do you know what that is? Millions of tuberculosis germs.
A tiny bit of spit from a sick man was smeared
on here and it was put away in a warm place.
The germs grew like a field of corn.
[Robert:] Oh, so when a few germs on the lungs
of a sick person get into the lungs of another,
they start growing?
[Doctor:] That's exactly right and that is
why sick people should be in the sanatorium.
There, they can't spread the seeds of their
disease to others.
We fight a range fire by clearing a strip.
The fire can't jump.
[Narrator:] Now you see Robert, why your people
suffer so much from tuberculosis. They crowd
together, somewhat careless about spitting.
When people are not clean, it becomes easy
for the germ to get from one to another. Some
people don't eat right and they become weak
and cannot fight the germs.
[Sound of sheep baaaa-ing]
[Narrator:] Sheep-dipping time. From all directions
for miles around, the sheep and goats are
brought to be dipped in a harmless solution
under the direction of government experts.
This ensures a fine, healthy crop of wool.
Everybody has a good time, everybody helps.
But the heavy work is done by sturdy young
men like Don.
[Sounds of sheep, gates opening and closing, splashing, people shouting to one another. Men are shown handling and dipping the animals.]
[A man is shown crouching, covering his mouth. Then he is helped to a waiting car, and the driver starts the engine.]
[As the car drives away, men on horseback come into view on the same dirt road.]
[A doctor in a white coat emerges from a house; the screen door slams.]
[Doctor:] Slow-Talker, Don is very sick. He
has tuberculosis.
The heavy work at the sheep dip started his lung to bleed.
[Robert:] The doctor said I was a good fighter.
I did what he said. Poor Don.
He did not understand. Nema, don't you think
the doctor should examine you too?
[Nema:] Oh, Robert, do you think I could have
it?
[Robert:] Anyone can have it. It is passed
from one to another.
[Slow-Talker:] I take Nema.
And a doctor shall examine me too.
[Doctor:] So you see, Nema's lungs are all
right. Now we look at your chest.
Here is the shadow of tuberculosis in your
lung. You have had it a long time, but it has
not killed you. You are a strong man, stronger
than the disease.
[Slow-Talker:] Then it is true that I have
given the disease to my family.
[The doctor nods solemnly.]
[Don:] Grandpa, will the cough kill my mother
too?
[Doctor:] Slow-Talker Don is very sick.
[Slow-Talker:] Now, I know the enemy. I too
will fight him with knowledge, your way.
Go my children. I stay. May you have many
children, healthy and strong.
[ Music ]
[A woman walks toward a small native dwelling and enters. A baby is in its mother's arms.]
[Woman:] What a fine baby you have. Grandfather
will be so proud.
[The mother is shown visiting Slow-Talker at the sanitorium and showing him the baby.]
[ Music ]
[Narrator:] Slow-Talker, we salute you. The
enemy has taken away your beloved Don and
Don's parents.
Now you yearn to go home, to mingle with the
people, the fields and hills and waters all
these you love.
Yet, you choose to stay. You will not bring
the enemy to their fireside. By your example,
the people again will conquer.
[ Music swells, and the couple with the baby are shown walking, then pausing and smiling at one another.]
[The End]